what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder this
is going to be my
falcon and the winter soldier episode 4
ending explained video plus a theory and
wow what an episode it was a great
episode and if you haven't seen it this
is your spoiler
warning it's an indian explained video
so naturally i'm going to be talking
about the ending a very very
brutal ending and if you have seen it
let me know what you would rate this
episode
out of 10 in the comments down below
first thing to note is i believe
this is the first time we've ever really
seen blood on captain america shield if
it's not the first time it is definitely
one of the very
very few times steve rogers was not a
brutal person in fact he was a man of
mercy and in fact
in this episode we saw a lot of john
walker realizing that he
is not steve rogers and in fact that's
where we're going to start off in that
big scene where the dora milajes show up
start fighting everybody and zemo gets
away this is actually a pretty critical
point to the ending
in the scene john walker being
incredibly stupid
goes up against the dora milaje now if
you're not familiar with who they are
if you didn't catch on they are from
wakanda and they are an elite group
of female bodyguards and wakandan
special forces
one of their main tasks is guarding and
protecting the king
and that's why they're here for zemo
zemo killed king t'chaka who they were
supposed to be protecting so naturally
they are trying to kill zemo now john
walker tries to go against them in his
own stupid way
and he gets his butt kicked and this is
where he gets the realization that he
just got his butt kicked by people who
weren't
even super soldiers john walker is
trying to be a good captain america and
in his head he is most likely trying to
be better than steve rogers however
steve rogers had the super soldier serum
and was an incredible person
and john walker has been getting his
butt kicked by the flax masters who are
super soldiers so he's starting to
realize that without the serum he can't
really keep up or
be as good as steve rogers was not only
physically but mentally as well
we hear him and lamar hoskins have a
very deep
conversation about what the serum could
do to a person now of course at this
point in time we know that all of the
serum has been destroyed except for one
vial that john walker has in his pocket
that nobody knows about
however he's afraid to take it because
he worries what will happen to him
morally if he takes it however his good
buddy lamar essentially tells him that
he's a good person and it's only going
to bring out his good person
even more essentially saying that the
serum would make a good person great and
a bad person even worse
this is a really important part that
we'll get to in just a bit
now in this episode sam tried to talk to
carly alone and it actually went very
well
he was appealing to carly and perhaps
maybe even started to kind of change her
mind but of course john walker showed up
and screwed the whole thing up but carly
did kind of trust
sam which is why she ends up calling
sam's sister she threatens her sister
and her two boys and she does this so
she can get a meeting with sam
and also tries to see what kind of man
sam really is
is he being led by this new captain
america or is he somebody that she can
trust
sam's sister gives him the location of
where to meet carly and him and bucky go
meet her
now she explains that she would never
hurt sam's sister and she doesn't even
want to hurt sam
but he's kind of in her way so she kind
of makes him an offer either to join her
or to simply let her go and get out of
her way so she can help the world at
least help them in her eyes
however sharon carter has been tracking
john walker and she locates him
he's moving in on the flax mashers so
once again he kind of screws everything
up
however this time it's going to have
some major consequences sam and bucky
take off to go and try to find
walker walker and hoskins enter the
building and the flax smashers end up
taking lamar and tying him up
now this is where we see john walker
smash through a door and he kind of just
stands there and kind of contemplates
something now what he's thinking about
here
is the fact that he is a lot stronger
now john walker actually took the super
soldier serum and he is feeling how much
stronger he is
it's starting to kick in he goes into
the next room and starts fighting with
one of the flag smashers and we see him
throw the shield and it gets shoved
inside
of the wall because he threw it so hard
his strength is already showing
sam and bucky arrive on the scene and
this is where we really start to see
that john walker took the serum we see
one of the flag smashers come flying out
of a door down the stairs he grabs a
metal pipe
goes to hit john walker but john walker
blocks it then he
bends it himself and throws the
flagsmasher he was once overpowered by
the super soldiers but now
him being a super soldier himself is not
overpowered
sam watches this whole thing go down and
he says what did you do
realizing that john walker did take a
super soldier serum however no time to
talk as john walker tells him that the
flag smashers have lamar
here sam and john walker start to fight
two of the flag smashers and here we
start to really see how strong john
walker is he throws the shield like
captain america and he's holding his own
against the flag smashers in fact he's
actually kind of winning for the most
part
sam also holds his own and bucky shows
up taking care of business
two flag smashers managed to hold down
john walker and
carly comes in with a knife about to
kill john walker but lamar has broken
three and he saves john walker by
tackling carly
however carly immediately punches lamar
and she's a super soldier and he isn't
so it sends him flying and he hits his
head
on a concrete pillar and it kills him
now lamar
was a good man he was simply an innocent
bystander
in all of this a person trying to be
good and everybody knows that
including the flag smashers which is why
when he dies they run
and they realize the severity of what
just happened lamar was famous he was
the sidekick of the new captain america
he was battle star
and even though i did predict that he
was going to die in a video i did
yesterday i'm really sad about this i
actually liked his character he kept
john walker in check which
is going to be a problem now that he's
gone as we can see by the very
last scene in this episode john walker
loses it
but i don't blame him they essentially
just killed his best friend
and now with super soldier serum pumping
through his veins
he runs after the flag smashers he jumps
through the window
does a superhero landing on top of a car
and although it was carly that killed
lamar
nico was the first flag smasher that
john walker caught up to throwing the
shield at him
knocking him to the ground in which he
screams it wasn't me
and john walker knows that it wasn't him
he even says where is she but he doesn't
care because he's in a rage
with nico on the ground he starts to
throw the shield at him even more
knocking him back even more until
eventually
he raises the shield just like captain
america did to iron man and captain
america civil war
although instead of just going for the
ark reactor to depower iron man's suit
john walker in this case bashes nico
until he kills him he straight up
brutally murders him in front of a lot
of people who are all recording on their
phones
everything that just happened so
essentially the whole entire
world is about to see the new captain
america brutally and viciously murder
somebody
so what happens from here well john
walker is most likely not going to be
able to remain being captain america
the us government will most likely not
want somebody who just
viciously murdered somebody in front of
the entire world thanks to the internet
to be their symbol of their country to
be the symbol of hope
this is ultimately going to lead to sam
finally getting the shield we've seen
sam with the shield enough
times and all the trailers and the tv
spots that we've gotten for the falcon
and the winter soldier
and with only two episodes left it's
about time he gets the shield in the
next episode so what i believe is going
to happen is either john walker is going
to come to his senses himself and
give up the shield to sam or the us
government is going to try and track
down
john walker or if it gets pretty extreme
and intense which this last episode
definitely was
sam and bucky could even take the shield
from him clearly john walker is in an
enraged state right now
he pretty much pulled the star-lord he
lost control over the death of a loved
one
and pretty much screwed everything up
but honestly i blame him for a lot i
blame him for messing up the
conversation between sam and carly and a
lot of other stuff but i don't blame him
for going crazy
after lamar got murdered i can
definitely put myself in his position
and see how he would go so crazy and
seek revenge
especially with a new dose of super
soldier serum flowing through his veins
and another thing is zemo escaped will
zemo return on his own
or will they have to track him down i
believe that he will actually return on
his own
in the falcon and the winter soldier
episode 3 there were times where zemo
could have escaped but he actually
returned i believe this is because he
is actually using sam and bucky to try
and get rid of the super soldiers he
genuinely wants to get rid of the super
soldiers this was his mission before
captain america civil war this is his
mission now and he said he has no
intentions on leaving his work
unfinished
he disappeared to escape the dora milaje
but i think he'll come back when the
coast is clear
but let me know what you think about
this in the comments down below do you
think zemo is going to come back on his
own or they'll have to hunt him down
and let me know in the comments down
below what you think is going to happen
to
john walker don't forget to subscribe to
stay up to date on the latest marvel
news and the falcon in the winter
soldier don't forget to like the video
and for live updates you can follow me
on instagram twitter and
tick tock as always thank you all so
much for watching woof